I thought I would be an exception I
thought I would be special case yeah I'm
gonna be looking real good ones this is
over didn't think it would happen to me
I thought I was safe
hey it's me look I'm gonna do more
makeup I'm gonna go I'm going to work
today and I'm going to do my makeup and
we're gonna see what people speak
I'm Emily I thought it would be cool to
challenge myself to only spending five
dollars on makeup I had an allergic
reaction to the cheap makeup that I
bought which sounds like it's not a
surprise except for me it was the week
that I did this challenge I was watching
my cousin's dog it's got to be the dogs
it's the only thing about my day and my
routine this week that is been different
okay so it ended up being five dollars
and 40 cents with cats which I think I
can allow because it's the government so
I think when it's all said and done it's
gonna be like a very natural sunkissed
kind of look I forgot
[Music]
and then you're just gonna want to blend
it that's fine
beep can you see it oh-oh-oh dry this is
it this is my final luck yeah I think I
can work with this did it I did it I
like it
oh yeah
[Music]
it's still on and you know what I'd
probably use this makeup again because
why not still here look I don't
typically have super sensitive skin I
put a lot of weird it on my face before
I never had any issues cut to my face
blowing up my face being itchy a rash
all over my cheeks in my eyelids and my
forehead down to my chin if you want my
body and you think I'm sex become on
sugar and let me know you know really my
face up I'd wash my face and then put on
vitamin E at night just like this dude
be thick and I'm just like holy stir
Iser type situation so I did that and I
used the hydrocortisone Korean I use the
max amount I could I think the moral of
the story is to just actually do your
research and know what you're putting on
your face a lot of times some red dyes
and makeups are bad I were blush I wore
it on my cheeks and I put it on my
eyelids apples to temple we're on the
outside
ooh nice sunset eyes here luckily it's
gone away and it was indeed just an
allergic reaction okay fine don't even
risk it you'll end up with a doctor's
bill
and embarrassing skin things you deserve
better quality it's your face if it were
your leg whatever sure but it's your
face
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]